Hello there!
Let’s suppose you are Microsoft and you
are releasing a huge and awesome model.
How do you make it obvious it is the
best, the biggest, the real thing?
Correct, you compare your numbers
of parameter against the literature,
make a beautiful plot where
you are the top of the line!
So congrats, now everyone is hailing
you like you’re the best of the best.
And you might as well be, Ms. Coffee
Bean is not here to claim otherwise.
But what does the number of parameters
tell us about a model anyway?
We came across a paper that tells us about the
bigger picture: It argues that the number of
parameters alone is not enough to compare against
other models and that reporting one number
only about a model can be highly misleading
when it comes to describing its efficiency.
In other words, a high number of
parameters does not necessarily
mean that the model has high
capacity, nor that it is slow.
So, get ready to get your mind enlarged
as we welcome you to this AI Coffee Break!
Thanks to Aleph Alpha for sponsoring this video!
Stick around until the end of the
video to learn more about them.
Model comparisons. What is this all about?
Well, we need to measure scientific progress
in deep learning. One line of doing so is
to measure the models quality on specific
tasks or benchmarks and to measure how much
of a sensible output the model delivers.
But we do not talk about this today, nor
does this paper. Because today it’s all about
model efficiency which relates to: how much
training a model costs, how much one has to pay to
run inference for many users and how long a user
has to wait until the model delivers the answer.
To describe model efficiency,
the literature uses things like,
we cite, “the number of trainable parameters, the
number of floating-point operations (FLOPs), and
speed/throughput”. But the point of this paper is,
that if one chooses the “right” cost indicators,
one can create a more favorable picture for
the model’s efficiency than it is in reality,
and that model comparisons relying on
only some of these metrics can result
in unfair and incomplete comparisons.
This is what the authors call the
“efficiency misnomer”. In other words,
to avoid the current situation where people
are just choosing the metrics they shine
at and ignore the others, the
authors propose that… well:
All metrics should be reported when it
comes to comparing architectures in general.
But what are these metrics and why does
one measure alone not suffice to describe
the computational cost of the model? Why
is Ms. Coffee Bean’s secret model of 530B
and one parameter, not automatically the best of
the best, and also not necessarily the slowest
since it reportedly – but don’t fact check
this – has the most parameters in the world?
Well, let’s look at the efficiency measure of
floating point operations (or FLOPs in short)
that is frequently used to measure
the computational cost in literature.
The more operations you have to do, the more
computations there need to be executed by a piece
of hardware. But as the authors point out, we
cite, “a model with low FLOPs may not actually be
fast, given that FLOPs does not take into account
information such as degree of parallelism (e.g.,
depth, recurrence) or hardware-related
details like the cost of a memory access.”
So supposing that model A has a lower number
FLOPs than model B, it might as well be that
model B is more efficient because the floating
point operations are not executed in sequence like
in a Recurrent Neural Network, but in parallel
all at the same time, like in a Transformer.
Or even more, maybe model B is better
suited for the hardware it runs on
and for example memory access is
faster for model B than for model A.
So even though model A has lower
FLOPs than B, model B could be
much more computationally efficient.
Then, let’s look at the number of
trainable parameters in a model, which is
also a widely used measure for efficiency.
But the authors here draw the attention to the
fact that, very few trainable parameters can
still be very slow, especially when the same
parameters are used in the same computation,
like it is the case with convolutions in CNNs
and with the feed forward layer in transformers,
where the same feed forward
network, so the same parameters
are used for each token, as we
discussed in a previous video.
So while the number of parameters from the
fully connected layer does not increase with
the sequence length for transformers,
the compute and memory definitely do,
because all these outputs for each feed forward
layer have to be computed and stored in memory.
The authors highlight that the number of
parameters of a model is a good proxy for
knowing whether the model fits in the memory,
but cannot be a cost indicator, or not alone.
Also, the number of parameters is often used to
imply the capacity of the model
in the sense of its expressive
power of capturing complex functions and
dependencies between input and output.
Which is not necessarily true, because
parameter sharing, which reduces the
effective number of parameters, does not
necessarily decrease the model expressivity.
Just think about it:
If we would remove the parameter sharing
in transformers and each token would have its
own feed forward network with its own parameters,
which would make the number of parameters
increase linearly with the sequence length,
would that increase the accuracy of the
model and would that model necessarily
learn a better function? No,
it wouldn’t, not necessarily.
I mean: we would have N position-specific
feed forward networks instead of just one,
but it’s questionable that this
would model anything better or
that it would even converge with
the data amounts we have currently,
because we would have removed an important
inductive bias of the transformer, which is: that
every token is treated the same, modulo what the
attention scores dynamically computed beforehand.
And yes, it does look like increasing the
number of parameters also increases the model
accuracy and quality, but this again,
is just an impression we get because the
increase of numbers of parameters usually comes
with an increase in training data and
with some specific architecture changes.
So no, it’s not just about the number of
parameters, but also about the architecture and
its inductive biases, the data, again the data
and then all the training gimmicks, of course.
Other metrics, like throughput and speed, which
relate to how much a user has to wait for the
model to give an answer, strongly
depend on hardware and sometimes,
simply on the skill of the programmer who
implemented the whole thing and does not
necessarily speak of an architecture on itself.
So this measure again, if used on its own,
is not a fair comparison between models.
And let’s follow the paper a little closer and
dive into the discrepancy between the training
and inference scenarios, that adds a
whole new dimension to the discussion.
Depending on context, training, inference or
even both can be more important to look at.
For example, Ms. Coffee Bean might not have
the data, the compute, enough money to pay the
electricity bill of the TPUs and GPUs that
Microsoft and Google and other likes have,
to train a huge model on billions of data
samples, but she does have enough VRAM to
load the model and fine-tune it on more tasks.
This is one of the appealing aspects of the
pre-train and fine-tune paradigm, that one
general purpose model is trained just once
and the environmental damage is done only once,
and this training cost, we cite, “can be very
small compared to the inference cost when a model
is deployed to be used by many, many users.”.
But in cases where retraining
has to be done very often,
like it is the case with recommender systems
that have to be kept up to date with the user
preferences and available content at any moment,
the training cost can become very important again.
On the other hand, if the inference efficiency
is the bottleneck because the deep-learning based
application runs on mobile phones, then
the inference speed is very important.
So we have seen how different measures can
disagree when it comes to describing efficiency
for the same model and that one measure of
efficiency alone can be highly misleading.
Also, the number of parameters alone
is not a measure for much else than:
how large a storage the model needs and that
the more efficiency metrics a paper reports,
the better, especially to be sure that nobody
“misses out” on the unfavorable metrics.
And speaking of companies that have the means
to crunch the numbers for really large models,
let’s introduce our sponsor: Aleph Alpha.
Aleph Alpha’s vision is quite simple: to
be the leading European company researching
and creating next-generation
strong artificial intelligence.
Think of it as a Europe’s OpenAI, but then forget
this again, as it puts a European twist to it. I
love this, a little bit of competition in
AI from Europe will benefit everyone, no?
Aleph Alpha’s European approach and
datasets have an impact beyond pure
language understandin. Uu, this
means their going multimodal!
So what they do best at Aleph Alpha is research
and development in AI with a European focus. They
have a diverse team of currently more than
30 senior experts from all relevant fields,
working relentlessly to create truly
transformative AI-technology, which
shall lead to new ways for
human-machine collaboration.
Going off-script now: I know some of the
people working there and they are great!
From research to development to implementation: AI
must benefit all of society and that’s why Aleph
Alpha strives to align modern generalizable
AI research sustainably with ethical values.
And to achieve that, they search for
the best talent and partners. So,
if you’re looking for a job, makes
sure to check out Aleph Alpha.
For more information, visit their
website, or follow them on Twitter.
See the links in the description below.
Thanks for watching this
episode. If you enjoyed this,
do not forget to tell your own
coffee beans about this channel.
Okay, bye!